oggi sono qui per parlarvi di tutti si
aspettano che io parli delle cose
positive che ha prodotto internet che
sta producendo internet oggi ma io sono
qui anche a parlare delle cose negative
che internet sta producendo che i
monopoli che si sono creati all'interno
di internet stanno favorendo e che in
qualche modo noi dovremo cercare di
sradicare o di rimuovere affinché il
progresso il progresso scientifico possa
possa cominciare da capo per andare
avanti
internet a tre livelli il il primo
livello di internet è rappresentato
dalle infrastrutture
quando noi parliamo di infrastrutture
pensiamo a tutte quelle società che si
occupano appunto di darci i segnali
perché noi possiamo comunicare per
esempio c'abbiamo live altri negli stati
uniti qui avrete le varie società
telefoniche queste nel livello 1
teoricamente i problemi di cui vi
parlavo poco fa non dovrebbero esserci
perché si tratta di società che comunque
ci danno un servizio e che fanno sì che
dopo di un pagamento di questo servizio
voi possiate comunque navigare
utilizzare la rete però se voi andate a
controllare le vostre bollette
telefoniche
vi rendete conto come il servizio è
sdoppiato in due è sdoppiato in quello
che noi chiamiamo download speed la
velocità di scaricamento dei dati dalla
rete in quello che noi chiamiamo athlon
speed la persona in cui voi fornite dati
alla rete stranamente la velocità di
upload cioè ogni volta che voi vendete
un informazioni alla rete è sempre più
lenta della velocità di download e noi
continuiamo a non spiegarsi il perché di
tutto questo problema per quale motivo
noi non siamo più liberi o non abbiamo
la stessa velocità ogni qual volta
vogliamo vendere dei contenuti alla rete
ma siamo strà ve lo c nel momento in cui
compriamo dei contenuti dalla rete
sicuramente i contenuti che noi
compriamo dalla rete di compriamo sempre
dagli stessi signori sempre dagli stessi
servizi che voi conoscete benissimo
ebbene quelli arrivano alla velocità
della luce tutti gli altri arrivano
molto più lentamente
il secondo livello di internet è
rappresentato dalla governance di
internet cioè quando internet fu creato
da dart internet qualcuno pensò di
fornirgli un sistema di governance un
governo un governo che gli desse un po
delle regole regole per l'acquisizione
dei dei domain regole per l'acquisizione
dei vari numeri collegati di domain
queste regole dovrebbero essere portati
avanti dalla governance di internet la
governance di internet teoricamente ha
gli stessi poteri di vigilanza che
avrebbe un governo all'interno di uno
stato poteri di vigilanza che dovrebbero
arrivare lì affermare per esempio la
divulgazione di video di decapitazioni
ultimamente tutti noi stiamo vedendo
quanti quante persone vengono uccise
vengono poi trasmessi questi video da
parte di queste organizzazioni
terroristiche
all'interno della rete e nessuno ferma
questi video perché nessuno ferma questi
video perché con molta probabilità a
questi video fanno rating con molta
probabilità questi video sviluppano dei
dati che a qualcuno interessano e grazie
a questi dati qualcun altro poi
realizzare dei prodotti pubblicitari
promozionali all'ultimo livello di
internet che io ritengo il primo
matematicamente primo abbiamo la
struttura economica l'internet economy
cioè i nostri social network i nostri
search engine tutto quello che insomma
in internet oggi sta realizzando
profitti ed è questo livello che
teoricamente dovrebbe essere separato da
tutti quanti gli altri che oggi in
internet sta creando un po di problemi
sta creando un po di problemi perché in
realtà pur non volendo abbiamo
realizzato e abbiamo fatto sì che in
internet si realizzasse un monopolio un
monopolio che ha
come interesse ultimo l'arricchimento
stiamo anche verificando che l'interesse
ultimo di questi monopoli molte volte
non è neanche il progresso tecnologico
perchè per esempio si parlava delle
nuvole si parlava della nuvola virtuale
dei servizi cloud i servizi cloud se
arrivano principalmente per archiviare
dati ma poi anche per servire per per
offrire servizi di computo alla gente
servizi di computo che quindi vanno in
qualche modo a creare un distacco tra i
vostri computer e la rete
mi spiego meglio se avete bisogno di
utilizzare dei software molto complicati
li potete oggi trovare online e quindi
c'è qualcuno che vi offre questi
software una delle più grandi e quindi
anche questo è un grande business uno
dei più grandi problemi che la rete ha e
la velocità di trasmissione dei dati
velocità di trasmissione dei dati che in
internet circa la velocità della luce
300.000 chilometri al secondo
quindi teoricamente se noi abbiamo un
server posizionato dall'altra parte del
mondo
il segnale di processamento da noi a
quel server cimenterà circa mezzo
secondo per arrivare da noi sono dei
numeri che magari non rappresentano
molto però per quanto riguarda internet
per quanto riguarda il computer world
rappresentano tantissimo mezzo secondo
distrugge tutto e sono le latenze ma
perché questo viene fatto se internet
doveva essere decentralizzato cioè se
internet doveva comunque per sé tanti
centri che potevano spostare questi dati
dove potevano essere archiviati
invece oggi noi abbiamo ai grandi server
di proprietà delle solite compagnie che
preferiscono a centrare i dati e offrire
dei servizi offrire dei servizi che
altrimenti non si potrebbero fare con i
nostri piccoli computer per esempio oggi
giorno noi abbiamo nel mondo i
cosiddetti super computer ne abbiamo
qualcuno negli stati uniti si chiama
tighter ne abbiamo qualcuno qui in cina
il mix
questi computer immaginate ve ne hanno 3
milioni 120 mila processori oltre un
milione di ram e consumano quanto la
città di bari sono enormi e consumato
tantissimo con questi computer noi
riusciamo a fare delle operazioni che
con i computer di casa non riusciremo a
fare come per esempio molecole di alcuni
farmaci si può creare una sorta di
animazione però comunque come potete
immaginare e è comunque qualcosa di
molto complicato da poter creare questo
computer è grande quanto la l'ateneo
universitario di bari
e allora qual è la risposta a tutto
quanto questo oggi la risposta si chiama
quantum computing nella computazione
tradizionale noi parliamo in bit cioè
che cos'è il bis
se voi vedete questi questi quattro cubi
nel b tradizionale noi sappiamo per
esempio che se un elettrone si trova a
sinistra e nel cubo di destra non c'è
niente e così via
dall'altra parte abbiamo un beat 0 e 2 1
i nostri computer oggi ragionano
soltanto con sequenze numeriche 0 e 1
questo significa che conoscono soltanto
un accesso era uno spento con nostro
soltanto un sì o un no un essere ed un
non essere non c'è niente
il mezzo non si viene a realizzare
quella che tutti noi speriamo che si
possa penalizzare che la falsi theory
cioè la possibilità di dire ma questo
oggetto è bianco o è nero e grigio il
computer questo non lo sanno non
riescono a ragionare in questo modo
nella teoria quantistica invece che
einstein ci perse soltanto tempo più di
cento anni fa e la teoria quantistica
noi abbiamo qualcosa che praticamente si
rappresenta in questo modo abbiamo
elettroniche si posizioni che si
posizionano entrambi nei due qb questo
che cosa sia presente a questo punto
quindi e 10 o 11
siamo davanti al beat 0 al beat 1
siamo davanti ad un grande in azioni
quantistica abbiamo sia 10 che 11 per
qualcuno può dire no ma
attenzione come mai questo è strano
il cervello umano lavora esattamente in
questo modo io adesso sto parlando con
voi
sto pensando sto cercando di mettere
assieme ai miei discorsi quello che devo
dirvi e il nostro cervello i neuroni ci
sono più neuroni che si stanno dedicando
a questo calcolo esempio in natura
l'ossigeno viene rappresentato colpo 2
con due atomi di ossigeno legati da
questi questo legamento bipolare dove al
centro di questo legamento c'è un
elettrone la verità che questo non
succede i chimici cercano sempre di
capire dove si trovi questo elettroni in
realtà questo elettrone risponde alle
regole della super position cioè questo
lettore si muove e si posiziona sui due
sui due atomi creando un unione tra di
loro che è l'essenza della vita su
questo pianeta e la coesione molecolare
che da due atomi crea una molecola
qualsiasi oggetto qualsiasi corpo la
materia su questo pianeta risponde alle
regole più artistiche e alla coesione
molecolare quindi dovreste esserne
felici di averla come può un computer
quantistico aiutare l'evoluzione il
progresso rispetto a un computer
tradizionale qui abbiamo un computer
quantistico
entrambi devono cercare di calcolare le
distanze che ci sono da questo mino alle
varie uscite alle quattro uscite così
ragiona un computer tradizionale oggi in
modo sequenziale uno alla volta il
computer fa questi calcoli
questo è quello che fa il nostro
processore così invece è come ragiona un
computer quantistico in simultanea
perché gli elettroni si si moltiplicano
e vanno ad occupare esattamente tutte
quante queste uscite
tutto questo quindi porterebbe voi lo
immaginate bene ad uno sviluppo
tecnologico incredibile che oggi
purtroppo non sta
avvenendo in modo continuo ci sono tanti
ricercatori che si stanno occupando di
queste di questo tipo del computer
quantistico però ancora siamo lontani
in conclusione cosa volevo dire in
conclusione volevo semplicemente dire
che purtroppo siamo di fronte a un mondo
dove per poter far funzionare quello che
facciamo dobbiamo rivolgersi a dei
mostri così grandi per quanto invece con
l'utilizzo di due qubit grandi quanto
più o meno un virus noi atterremo una
macchina molto più veloce è sicuramente
la potremmo utilizzare per il progresso
scientifico per il progresso tecnologico
progresso in medicina progresso in
chimica ovunque
a tutt'oggi siamo arrivati sulla luna ma
non riusciamo ancora ad avere un
computer che possa effettuare dei
calcoli e delle per esempio delle
simulazioni di molecole molecole
utilizzate da industrie farmaceutiche
con il computer quantistico
questo potrebbe succedere infine
l'ultima considerazione che che mi è
dovuta e che internet nasceva come un
sistema che doveva essere libero e
democratico dove tutti potevano dovevano
potersi un può affermare per qualche
strana ragione qualcuno sta utilizzando
metodi perché certi tipi di navigazione
certi tipi tutto quello che noi facciamo
venga centrato da qualche parte e questo
qualcuno oramai è diventato così forte
da non permettere al progresso di
evolversi in questo modo si investe
sempre di più nel realizzare e droni che
portino internet alle scimmie
dell'africa ma non si pensa di investire
denari per la realizzazione dei cube it
per la realizzazione di un computer
quantistico che possa davvero risolvere
con le nanotecnologie problemi del mondo
io ritengo anche le soluzioni a problemi
come il cancro potrebbero nascere
dall'utilizzo di un computer quantistico
grazie
[Applauso]